owen and walker it is such a pleasure to
meet both of you um first of all what
gadget or power do you wish you had from
the movie in real life that's easy for
me the fanny pack
[Laughter]
what
oh my god i feel like that uh no i think
um although i do feel like fanny packs
have gotten kind of a bad rap uh but i
think the actual sort of
you know the the jacks kind of uh you
know layer his secret headquarters that
would be pretty cool i think most guys
have you know the cliche kind of the man
cave where they watch sports and things
and
uh this would be the ultimate
ultimate
version of that
what about you walker
um
i'm gonna have to agree with owen to the
fanny pack
you know or for maya's jacket my jacket
was pretty cool yeah
yeah
growing up which superhero did you look
up to in movies or comics or who do you
look up to now
um i think for me you know spider-man
was maybe the one that uh i really liked
as a kid and then as i got older
although you've never seen like kind of
a movie with them but the silver surfer
uh
that always seemed really cool
okay okay walker
uh well
it was spider-man for like the first six
years but after that i think it's
deadpool
okay okay
fair and which leads me and i hate to do
this to you walker but who's better at
fighting off the bad guys is it owen or
your adam project co-star ryan reynolds
well
that's a that's alright question um
it depends are we talking like deadpool
ryan or adam right oh
i mean
now that we've added this layer you get
to choose i guess now we have three
people to
choose from
you can be honest walker i don't think
it's going to hurt ryan's feelings too
bad
i think
i think
they all love great hair
dad just said to me
um
really builds the suspense i know i'm
like
i can't handle it
um i mean one of them has a lightsaber
one of them has like a
an ironman suit uh
i mean it's i don't know i it's a very
hard question and yeah
i feel bad now i feel like i put you in
a bad position and you weren't you
weren't ready you weren't ready
maybe i don't know i think that's i
think it's a tie because the guard will
keep killing deadpool and then deadpool
will keep coming back
also because owens here just say oh when
owen
thank you
well done well done
so this is obviously a huge family movie
for sure um owen when you do a movie
like this who are you most excited to
show it to in your family
um
you know it's funny when i first was
reading the script um i was kind of
reading some of the scenes to my uh you
know to my two boys wanting to kind of
gauge their reaction especially the
stuff with kind of walker and the girl
and his friends and seeing kind of how
they were really was what happens next i
took that as kind of a good scene a good
sign so um i think i'll be
you know i'll be excited to sort of see
their reaction and then
i have to admit that luke my younger
brother sent me
a picture he had seen the billboard in
lord in los angeles and he said he was
excited to see it so
uh yeah i'd love to see uh what my
brothers think i think they're gonna i
think they're gonna be into it
yeah
walker for you is there one person in
your family that you're just so excited
to show this movie to
um
probably my brother my brother loves
superheroes as much as i do almost
so i think he's gonna like this a lot
yeah
so a life with secret headquarters owen
for you given how famous you are
is a secret headquarters something you'd
be into and if so what would you like in
there if you could put anything in there
um
i guess if i
um it's maybe where i would want it i i
think i'd have to say hawaii
you know every state is great but
there's something about hawaii and the
idea of having a
secret headquarters although the the
whole state kind of with the incredible
kind of nature uh feels like its own
sort of secret hq so um
yeah i guess that was what that would be
what i would say
yeah are you like a binge watching tv
kind of guy are you into video games do
you play pool like what's going on in
there
well those ones you just said definitely
pool definitely ping pong and you know
what's actually fun
is pickleball i don't know if you played
pickleball but uh it's you play it sort
of on a tennis court but it's like a
quarter the size and so
um i think that would be cool to have
there maybe a go-kart track i mean if
we're if we're gonna indulge and wish
fulfillment then um yeah i think i'd
have to put that in there
i love it and lastly
are we gonna see any movies with you
coming up with vince vaughn or ben
stiller you've had some amazing classics
that we all look forward to seeing you
again yes um i think you nev you never
know but uh it's funny i've been talking
to ben earlier but um
yeah i've worked on a lot of movies with
those guys so uh it'd be a shame if we
didn't find something i bet we do
i hope you do okay well thank you so
much owen walker pleasure to meet you
thank you for your time guys
thank you
you